can I read Trump's statement is that
okay yeah okay wow district attorney
Bragg just illegally leaked the various
points and complete information on the
pathetic indictment against me okay all
right great I know the reporter and so
unfortunately does he this means that he
must be immediately indicted to his
calling for an indictment of brag now if
he really wants to clean up his
reputation he will do the her honorable
thing and as district attorney indict
himself well where is the leak well I
don't think he leaks he links to the
lick but I'm sure it's on Twitter
somewhere he will go down he will go
down in judicial history and his Trump
hating wife will be I'm sure very proud
of him D.A Bragg just illegally leaked
the 33-point indictment there are no
changes or surprises from those he
leaked days ago out of the grand jury no
crime by Trump what a mess Brad should
resign now this says 34 felony counts
for falsification of business records
felonies yeah 34 felonies none of this
are misdemeanors but they up they
upgraded upgraded it due to the uh what
was it like election
stuff the campaign Finance regulation so
they applied a federal law to a state
statute so what I think is illegal yeah
and what I think is funny too is that it
would be a campaign contribution for a
federal race right which is governed by
the Federal Election Commission not the
New York not the New York D.A but also
the idea that uh president Trump's
campaign would have been adversely
affected by him allegedly having had a
relationship with a porn star is also
ridiculous I don't think anyone would
have cared about that like I don't think
that they're addressing that information
was necessarily there's so many attack
vectors here that are just special yeah
there are a lot of them so it was class
E felonies which is the lowest level of
felonies I'm just going to challenge
everyone do not fall for this 34 that's
what I'm garbage so it's like if there's
one Financial crime and then they sent
out a massive email to 34 people they
could be like but the 34th thing is a
total PR move to try to get you to
believe that this is a much harsher more
serious crime I'll give you you an
example let's think of a crime that and
there's going to be no handcuffs and no
money let me think of a crime that we
all know of that I could give you a
really good example of okay uh O.J
Simpson okay let's he did it but that's
a separate issue but you could have a
400 count indictment for fleeing the
police and running a red light and you
know he was in the Dodge Durango
remember that white Dodge Durango or
whatever he was in yeah right yeah I'm
sorry thank you for the fact check um
that that would be a 400 count
indictment right but it's really
centered on one or two events does that
make sense so that you can extend an
indictment again this is why prosecutor
overreach is so incredibly you know
severe and such a danger to our society
is that this 34 count thing is a PR
Masterpiece because if Donald Trump was
indicted on one count but 34 sound
serious did he break into the embezzle
money did he also do wire fraud did he
and remember a lot of the statutes in
the way the Crim terminal code is
written is not about the actual crime
itself usually it's about all the
supporting different criminal codes they
can get that you tripped the wire in the
process of committing the crime right so
the old adage is that they got Al Capone
on taxes that that's a bad example the
better one is that they've overwritten
the criminal code they've deepened it to
such an extent why are fraud check fraud
you know falsification of Records lying
under oath obstruction of justice that
eventually it creates these counts that
can give the prosecutor an advantage
does that make sense yeah absolutely
it's like uh getting having your bank
account go to a negative and then every
day you make a payment and you just keep
getting these negative charges over and
over and over again but it's really only
because that one it was done unjustly
yeah that's right that's that's a good
example and so the the this 33 34 count
thing is is brilliant we found the
leaked indictment or is Trump just I
think it was Jesse Waters who was
reporting on it I haven't found anything
on Twitter why would he leak it to Jesse
Waters
it happened he may be just referring to
what Trump said so I've not seen
anything on Twitter I searched for it
didn't find any uh searched Google
Twitter I didn't find anything so
you know maybe it's circulating among
journalists but you see what I mean you
saw the statement he wrote right
um
yeah Jesse Waters apparently I think was
just quoting Trump perhaps saying that
there's more evidence that Bragg
committed a felony than Trump
okay well Trump seems pretty forceful in
this statement and Waters was on air two
hours ago so I don't think that's right
I think that Trump just got a heads up
from a reporter that this indictment's
about to drop in a store or a reporter
emailed his team my guess we've got the
indictment I know the reporter and
unfortunately does he it's Maggie
Haberman I can almost guarantee it
there's only so many reporters he knows
that he would say he knows I will put
money it's Maggie Haberman if I'm wrong
I will finish this glass of wine would
Greg have just given a reporter the
indictment I mean think about it how
many reporters has proximity to the DA's
office on this beat that works the New
York circuit and also knows Trump that
narrows it down to Maggie Haberman
unless I mean there's other reporters
too but my smart money's on Maggie
Haberman about to drop a story so I
would keep your eye on her Twitter feed
yeah I could be wrong I could be wrong
it could be the worst take ever but
that's just based on his statement he
probably got an email to his press
office hi this is Maggie Hammer of the
New York Times just wondering if you
have any last minute comment here you
know we just received the indictment in
full and then he's trying to preempt it
with his statement that's my I guess is
that that's he says it's a felony to uh
leak an indictment I have no idea I mean
the New York Times via Haberman remember
received Donald Trump's tax returns in
October 2020 illegally and was never
held criminal criminally accountable for
that the same thing they went after
James O'Keefe for remember they rated
James O'Keefe's apartment for allegedly
receiving
a document a diary which is not even
they said it was stolen yeah it's stolen
even though government tax returns are a
much higher privacy threshold than a
private diary that you obviously didn't
care enough about to get out of a
halfway house that was a halfway house
she was in it was like a recovery home
like roommate or whatever yeah I don't
mean to slander her but yeah I mean some
sort of thing
um so we'll see but my guess is you're
going to see a story drop here rather
momentarily that's me reading between
the lines from Haberman I don't know
that's my guess
it could be CNN by the way they were
leaking to CNN previously too so but my
guess is if Trump says I know him
remember Maggie got several Oval Office
interviews with Trump and that's one of
his you know
that's one of his uh you know and by the
way we have to remember that if the
foundational crime allegation against
Trump falls apart all of the 33 charges
crumble so if you're able to get to the
essence of the charge which is did
Donald Trump break Finance campaign
Finance law by administering 130 000
payment so let's go through the fact can
I go through the facts surrounding this
Tim is that helpful yeah yeah let's go
okay first of all he did not write the
check Michael Cohen did
Michael Cohen is not a trustworthy
witness this guy Michael it's Michael
isakov isakov from The Washington Post
uh drink the water I gotta drink this
water I was wrong that was your bet you
know if you drink more than four ounces
of water at a time it makes you feel
like you have to but I was right about
the fact that a reporter was about to
drop yeah it's with Yahoo news Yahoo
news
exclusive Trump to be charged Tuesday
with 34 felony counts but spared
handcuffs and mug shot
the spared mug shot the mugshot would
have made him so much money when was
that published three that was published
an hour ago yeah just a little bit ago
but are you sure this is where they
actually got the leak this doesn't look
like A source told Yahoo news this is
from this just came out this is not you
don't think that's the thing because
they have his statement in here I could
be wrong I want a copy I want like a
yeah I want a docu cloud upload right
right you know what I'm talking about
exactly but here's the other facts okay
that Michael Cohen administered the
payment okay Michael Cohen wrote in an
official letter to the FEC the Federal
Election Commission that this payment
was on his own behalf and Donald Trump
never reimbursed him so the question
will be do they have a record of Donald
Trump reimbursing Michael Cohen for a
sum or a like some that could convince a
jury that that Michael Cohen lied to the
FEC he lies all the time the third thing
there is nothing illegal about
administering an NDA there's nothing
illegal to it Bill Clinton did all the
time CEOs did all the time rappers do it
all the time right it's it's done quite
frequently half of them so this it might
be the isakov story which would be
strange but he's saying that uh they're
Class E felonies of falsifying business
records up to four he's in prison the
New York law enforcement says it is
extremely unlikely a first-time offender
would see jail time there will be no
arrest there will be no cuffs there will
be there will be no uh mug shot are
there going to be cameras in the
courtroom I don't ask today to not have
cameras in the courtroom yeah Trump's
saying he doesn't want it yeah and
remember issakov was one of the original
Steel dossier League stories remember so
he has an end to that's right law
enforcement and Intel agencies but
anyway the whole the Crux of the
argument with Trump will come down to
intent and also the quality of their
Witnesses I don't know who Alvin Bragg
is going to bring you know called to
testify other than like Cohen yeah
Michael Cohen who's a convicted liar
went to jail for a line in front of
Congress and so you know this thing if
they can if the elemental charge which
is falsification of business records
right is is the cult is the whole ball
game here regarding did he pay Cohen
back for it I saw a check a year later
paid for 35 Grand it was 130 000 payment
he paid Cohen Trump paid Cohen 35 and
he's doing other business with Cohen so
how can you draw one to one it's all on
Cohen's testimony and remember Cohen's
own lawyer Costello or something this
guy went on Tucker he was very
persuasive said Colleen's a liar and
Cohen's such a liar that he goes he goes
and signs away his attorney-client
privilege
so that his lawyer then is able to go on
television and say yeah everything he
told us under attorney client seal let
me just tell you this guy's a complete
liar they added the statement after the
story dropped oh is that right this is
likely the story they probably reached
out to Trump's team and said okay it's
Michael issacoff so it's not Maggie
hibberman stand corrected chief of
course it was a good guess though
spokesman for
um Trump's legal team has not seen the
indictment or been briefed on the
details
yeah I don't know if they actually have
a copy of the indictment though if they
did right it seems really weird why
would you not like why would you not
work for Yahoo news yeah well
but why would you know they must pay
well
I guess I thought they were just an
aggregator you know they guess they're
doing their own stuff well yeah and they
got a scoop apparently I don't think it
doesn't there's nothing new here
yeah Jack wasobik has a tweet he said
the we've we've you know I'll paraphrase
the country is irrevocably damaged
there's none coming back from this yeah
I think that's right I don't agree with
that it's just we've seen how damaged
it's been over the last 70 years by the
banking Federal service you know that
the way they've made the Federal Reserve
is scandalous the way that they went to
that island and had Congress sign it
over Christmas of Jekyll Island yeah and
speaking about what's going on today
we've never seen anything like this
happen to a former president and there's
no question it's political unless of
course you gain from it politically I
think any any that confirms my argument
Democrat politicos are going to say it's
not political because they benefit from
it end of story when they see when
people see like oh look how horrible
this country has become for instance
with this banking Scandal you know where
our country looks like it's on its way
to bankruptcy you got to ask yourself do
you want to maintain this country now
and and I think that what helps is
perspective because I was just watching
about North Korea last night and you
know it's very possible remember that
auto warm beer story he came back all
comatose they think they just the North
Korean government just poisoned him and
sent him back so that he couldn't talk
yeah they just killed him in prison they
poisoned him bio weapons like that's the
other side of the coin if we lose this
Republic well and the what was it the um
North Korean leader Kim Jong-un which
one is is that is uh his daughter wore a
Dior like a whole Dior Ensemble to watch
a a missile test recently yeah I love it
which is there it is terrifyingly
concerning you know when Cult of
Personality goes out of control and one
person gets control of a small and she
gets Dior outfits and everybody else is
starving so you know rule of law law and
order it's not just law it's Law and
Order if your law produces chaos then
it's a bad law so if the country is
irrevocably damaged if there's no coming
back from it then what we need to create
something new there's no going back what
people need to do is but who's even make
money have families
do virtuous things repeated do virtuous
things repeatedly daily and be
disciplined and anchored to things that
are self-sufficiency being as
self-sufficient as possible and then uh
find someone who's who's legally allowed
to give you Financial advice and have
conversations about what do we do in
these trying times so I was thinking
about the the question we were talking
about with Colorado or the trans kids in
California and really these are not
legal questions I mean we can pass all
kinds of laws we can enforce all kinds
of laws but this is a problem that
exists in people's hearts you know yes
like that's my point about the Civil War
yeah that's a big issue here like if you
have a woman who to use your first
example is going to spite a man that she
once loved by murdering their
eight-month-old child before it's born
but this happens all the time there was
a story just recently this is right but
what I'm saying is that's a problem in
someone's heart that's not that's not
something a law can fix that's something
that's about the decline of morality the
decline of values the decline of love
you know there you go
literally just Google searched what you
said
VA mom who killed daughters and plot to
exact revenge on husband then called to
tell him get 78 years she she shot them
in their beds she drugged them and shot
them in their beds this story I saw this
five days ago yes five six days ago so
when we're talking about states that
allow the killing of children and states
that don't
my fear
is that you will get a father who will
say something as simply as she has no
right to take my son and kill him I'm
gonna get the boys together and we're
gonna go and stop her from doing it
they're not gonna I'm not saying I'm not
saying they're gonna come out and get
guns and be alike it's time to ride boys
I'm saying they're gonna be like let's
go find out where she is and stop her
from killing my kid and that's going to
escalate from there the state's gonna be
like she's allowed to kill your kid too
bad even if and I'm talking about a
point which the child is viable and can
survive outside the womb and the
husband's saying just let's instead of
killing it let's just deliver it and
then I'll take the baby and she says
nope it's gonna die now this woman goes
to prison because the babies were were
five and fifteen five and fifteen oh my
gosh a baby that is viable of living on
its own
can be killed in these States I am not
arguing the morality of abortion what
for those that are listening I am
arguing simply that there will be a
great vocabulary though you're using the
proper wording well but but if the baby
can survive on its own then it's being
killed I mean that's correct I agree
yeah if you have a father who says I
want the baby to live and a woman who
says don't know don't care the state
lets me do it you've got a very serious
moral Christ on your hands that's not
going to be solved by a a court order
that's correct every law can be passed
every judge can bang their gavel and the
father might still say you will not kill
my son yes and there will be a multitude
of these issues that are going to come
to the front and the question will be is
the Constitution still the law of the
land and it's crumbling in front of our
eyes
the Constitution is the greatest
political document ever written and we
are in a post-constitutional moment it's
brilliant founding fathers man yeah this
is this is because they built it on
Eternal wisdom and they knew central
banks were so dangerous yes they did
well even the National Bank was not
technically a central bank so you're
correct even Hamilton's idea of a
central bank would be different than
what our idea of a central bank where
like they run it out of Switzerland some
foreign
to the bank for international
settlements in Switzerland Hamilton's
idea of a national bank would have had
actual checks and balances by congress
not a separately chartered Federal
Reserve that is basically public private
but you're right even even Hamilton
would have found this current banking
system objectionable I understand that
there is a value of cohesion and having
a unified currency as a country it gives
us national identity we can all identify
with the dollar but we're in a we're in
a society where you can create your own
currency very easily with crypto so
maybe we just need to the whole Congress
handles money obviously they don't the
banking scandals offshore svb welcome to
bitcoin Sam bankman free yeah laundering
money through allegedly through his
company and now like so maybe we should
be able to all create our own currencies
I know it creates disillusion in some
way nationally you know Bitcoin is the
decentralized store of value that people
are already using look at the sound of
them but there's thousands and you can
create them on the fly right it's going
to be messy for a while the the dollar
is necessary though right now you think
we're divided now wait until we have our
everyone has their own currency yeah no
no wait until declining Brazil and China
have already cut a deal Saudi Arabia and
Iran are cutting a deal China's
brokering deals to end the Petro dollar
Americans are in for a very very rude
awakening it would impoverish this
country yeah empowers an understatement
I don't know yeah I don't know how you
would yeah we're concerned about
decimate that apocalypse how about that
yep economic although apocalypse isn't
necessarily bad it just means like the
Great Awakening the great uh uncovering
well it means starvation
they take a negative connotation maybe
because it's near the end of the story
in the Bible is that why probably but in
reality now we're just it's becoming
disclosed we the curtain has been lifted
we see the chaos we know what the
Federal Reserve is now that they've
formed it behind the scenes in 1913 not
everyone knows but you do it's being
revealed daily to new people Trump was
part of that Steve bannon's greatest
talking about but yeah in like loose
change lucrutkowski these people have
been talking about it for 20 years so it
is a form of Apocalypse not necessarily
A Bad Thing what do we do with
disclosure don't let your mind go crazy
don't don't go crazy it I understand why
you may want to because like people are
going to lose their jobs and they're not
going to have any food or a way to feed
their children and that's going to be a
problem as a result of what as a result
of the complete collapse of the Petro
dollar
so we don't make things we don't we have
excellent things but we make we make
some things let me make the can I make
the counter argument to all the doomsday
IPOs that don't actually have any
products well that is true there's a lot
there's a lot of Truth there so China
only represents about five percent of
our Imports less than people not Imports
are not Imports that's not correct our
total economic output so we could
survive without China but thankfully the
only benefit of this stupid proxy war in
Ukraine is that we're actually on okay
terms of Germany even though Germany
hates us right now they're going to be
fine with us Germany is a very
productive country they make stuff
Germany makes stuff and Germany is
basically a proxy sister economy of
America right they use the dollars the
world Reserve currency the year is
backed by the dollar Japan they make
stuff Japan and America are inseparable
especially with their Chinese skepticism
South Korea they make stuff they're
Inseparable the open question is what is
India going to do that should be the
whole Focus quite honestly of this
current government is to make sure India
does not fall into the good graces of
Russia or China they're natural
adversaries of China shouldn't be a hard
problem they hate the Chinese they've
never liked each other there's there's
natural built in tension there and
there's a massive developing Market in
Southeast Asia that hates China they
hate the CCP they want to use the dollar
Indonesia is a fast-growing country the
Philippines you have Vietnam you have
Cambodia of Laos these are fast
developing countries very industrious
people with ever increasing property
private property rights which is a
prerequisite to wealth creation and be
careful what you ask for the want is
manipulated China's economy is largely
built on a potemkin village you're right
we don't make stuff but this idea that
China has this Beast waiting to go
economically their house of cards too
and but it's not just about China it's
about the fact that we have been giving
away our manufacturing for a long time I
totally agree with that but I think we
can onshore that a lot quicker because
we have the natural production meaning
we have the natural production
capability we have natural resources
right so so let's just say China Cuts us
off okay let's say they say no more
vitamin C okay we could ramp up vitamin
C production in this country in 10
months if we wanted to we could do it
well Trump had that idea of starting to
bring a lot of penicillin should not be
made all that stuff right you can get
ideas for like Kodak factories Upstate
New York that's right you make vitamin C
out of black mold of all things right
yeah I mean the good stuff is yeah
unless it says naturally derived in the
ingredients from what I'm told it comes
from black mold that's creepy
aspergillus negro is what it's called
that's interesting yeah I prefer for my
oranges thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time